getting over the soy the fire-eaters no
better one
oh thank you me too no sadistic ladies
as you see I will eat a lean back
I'm from Santa Maria California and I am
Mexican and Irish nací en la ciudad a
San Salvador I was born in Havana Cuba
porin Salvatore Gia donde give Anita en
Holly 1s Thomas's preyas yokan estaba
Chiquita cami naba de una Montana a la
otra Montaigne a persona a la Yakima
Cano see stay off we are so long a
pintail pillow and I came to dólares
interest mucho dinero y this is a tip
nada
Oh mean Eddie hey I see you're cheap
cuz you're cheap not cheap he's looking
in the mirror but she's like I'm getting
old my skin she doesn't really talk
about herself
oh she talks about other people so be
like Ramon margarita margarita bro you
know no Maga Rita
Oh whele
Oh Ellen Oh No cristela Nando al gay
Sara you can talk to me what are you
doing where are you I can't talk missing
it
are you later quite don't tell me her
busy I call her again
did you see what margarita put on her
Facebook yesterday as her status mom
who's margarita margarita Jenny my god
II thought the girl went to graduation
nope I don't know she is mom
Oh Joey una vez la no Miyama una vez es
suficiente one time is enough this is
Sarah that's right acutally women kind
of watch Oh
it may have separate topic but uh she
goes like this and like this
I'm a full the dancer Oh gang signs
Alamo chicks
all right I'm gonna go now okay all
right all right
have you love you I love you mom hi I
don't say it like that
we went down a Lolita Oh stairs nice
Paris young sister de ver de hacer t ha
ha baby Toyota recuerdo pero Mira mucho
trabajo Bonita - shall I kiss - in
cheeky para - Lente's like the sister
that I am a hand down and my little
daughter my first my grandmother is
everything to me she's my world we have
a really close relationship especially
now that she could email me in facebook
me she was really young when she had me
I'm still young she would be like um not
all toy Barbies but your mom gets out at
5:00 so put the Barbies way at 3:00 but
I play Barbies and put makeup on her and
do her
Rondo Kundera Chiquito Anna yeah oh I'm
crying